hey guys how's it going I have been
incredibly busy over the past few days
I've been doing a ton of shoots for two
different Disney things one for the
upcoming big hero six movie and then
another for Disney Fantasia which I
actually managed to record another
impossible let's play on I literally
stuck the electro-stimulation things on
my body and made my arms and chest which
while I was trying to conduct Fantasia
it's really funny although a lot of
people be pretty worried about but no
lasting damage I'm only slightly twitchy
now but no more than I usually am so
I've got a ton of things I actually want
to show you some pictures from that I'm
actually bouncing today because I'm in a
good mood I have some pictures here of
like me shooting with other people of
the youtubers new people that I met and
I'm gonna be doing something tomorrow
with actual TV actors if you know of
Kate Micucci and let's do Jeff and it
was dude brace we're doing something for
a geek and sundry for werewolves the
card game and it's just gonna be a lot
of fun because I just got back from
costume designing and it was like real
movie stuff and it was things from
Deadwood and there were things from uh
some other western movies that I should
probably know about and I was just like
trying out all this stuff and I'm like I
don't know why I'm here on more youtuber
do banal 450 bit but in the sketch I'm
gonna be married to Felicia Day so you
can ship it or not ship it if you want
to probably shouldn't just for
professionalism sakes but either way I'm
gonna be the police today tomorrow and
be doing all this cool stuff and I'm
gonna be acting with other people and
I'm gonna be in there having fun and I
can't wait to do that we've been doing
all these shoots like starting from last
Wednesday I've been doing from 9:00 to
midnight 9:00 in the morning to midnight
all the shoots and I'm really happy to
say I've been keeping up with videos
like for the first time in a long time
idea I'm not coming on here to say like
sorry for only one video week I've been
like ah I've been doing videos like
almost every single damn and able
to videos even though I've been
incredibly busy that's why I'm all
bubbly and happily but there's other
reasons for a 200 also check out this
sick flip that this ninja did on the
shoot and then check out my equally
stupid walk afterwards like it's just
from a video that we're doing that's
coming out my channel pretty soon really
cool stuff they're doing special effects
are gonna have a big robot in there all
sorts of crazy stuff but I'm in a good
mood because this morning I was reading
for emails and yes I still do read
emails I don't have time to respond to
hardly any in comparison to how many I
get but I know that I do read your
emails whenever I can and there were
just some particularly touching stories
this morning I've heard from this mom
whose kid has autism and he only opens
up when he watches my videos and it was
just like really touching to hear that
you know my videos can actually help
people out with their daily lives you
know affect people in ways that I never
managed they could I always wanted to
make people laugh but know that they can
actually help bring joy to people and a
ton more people talking about how they
they are going through tough times in
their lives and you know my videos help
them smile and they don't think they
have anything to smile about and a lot
in response to how it's talked about
depression and never any nightmares just
how it helps people out and it helps
give people hope and Fagen and I'm blown
away by the fact that my videos can even
do that is something really heartwarming
to see and I finally feel like I'm to
the point in my life when I'm starting
to work on these really cool projects
and I'm starting to work on these bigger
things you know bigger than myself and
bigger than my channel and yet I'm so
happy that I'm still able to kind you to
connect with you guys I know with almost
4 million people now it seems like I
can't but just know I'm trying
I lose sleep everyday just because I
have to work harder and I don't mind I'm
not complaining about that at all well I
got first full night's sleep like
yesterday and I have to get up early to
do the shoots and then make videos for
you guys but I loved every minute of it
I love love love every minute in making
videos for you guys it's my favorite
thing in the world there's nothing I
would rather be doing
and it's these times when I'm able to
know that you know I'm dedicating myself
to something good that I feel really
really proud of what we've accomplished
and what were able to do oh and the next
charity livestream is going to be on
October 25th which is a Saturday and I
will be going back to Cincinnati where
I'll be able to see my family and
friends and hang out with them finally
again it's been a long time since I
moved out to LA but I'll be able to go
back there and hang out with them we'll
have a lot of fun I don't know what
charity we're going to be raising for
this month but we are going to be
selling hoodies I believe we're gonna be
selling hoodies and of various designs
because winter is coming up for a lot of
people bladers coming up nevermind but
either way we're going to be selling
hoodies and some other goodies for
charity and then the following month is
extra life so we will be doing the extra
life campaign I believe we'll be doing
that for the Cincinnati Children's
Hospital if not if since Children's
Hospital in the LA area where I live so
thank you all so much for your not
stuffs or I adored you you are the light
of my life to be the most cliched person
in the world but I'll you're the reason
I do this and it is just amazing and I'm
in such a good mood today so I'm gonna
go and I'm gonna record a bunch more and
then tomorrow I want to meet Felicia Day
worked at all the TV actors and it's
gonna be awesome
so I can't wait to do it I can't
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye